after a fast-paced season 7 the long
night of waiting for Game of Thrones
season 8 is upon us and according to
actor kit harington the final season is
going to be an absolute bloodbath a lot
has happened over the course of the last
seven seasons including the deaths of
over 200 named characters which has me
wondering whose neck will end up on the
proverbial chopping block next season
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm predicting the characters
likely to die in the epic final season
of Game of Thrones I'm also starting a
new Funko pop giveaway all you have to
do is be a subscriber to my channel and
leave a comment on this video for a
chance to win quick spoiler warning I'll
be reviewing major character arcs from
all seven seasons so far so take care if
you're not caught up let's kick off with
one the characters many of us love to
hate on Game of Thrones Cersei Lannister
back in season five Maggy the Frog made
a number of predictions for Cersei which
have come true including the death of
her three children so far however George
RR Martin's books include another
prophecy by Maggie that Cersei will be
choked to death by the valonqar which is
high Valyrian for little brother or
possibly little sister or little sibling
so could this mean we'll see Tyrion
strangle Cersei just like he did his
former lover Shae I don't know if it'll
be that simple
after all Jaime Lannister may be
Thirsty's twin but he's also slightly
younger than her season 7 has already
teased Jaime as a possible von Kahr for
example there's a scene which showed
Cersei and Jaime standing on a huge map
of Westeros with Cersei at the area
called the neck and Jaime by the area
known as the fingers and the two are now
estranged after she accused him of
treason when he chose to ride north
after she reneged on her agreement to
unite with Dany and Jon against the
White Walkers and remember you're on
Greyjoy's replied to Circe's accusation
that he killed his own brother you
should try it your unsaid it feels
wonderful so to prevent the prophecy or
because she feels they've betrayed her
will Cersei attempt to follow through on
her threats to kill her brothers yet end
up hoist by her own petard also with
each passing day Cersei seems to act
more and more like a mix of her father
Tywin and the Mad King Aerys Targaryen
the thing is Tywin was killed by Tyrion
and Jaime reluctantly killed the Mad
King to prevent him from carrying out
his crazy plan of setting the whole of
King's Landing on fire
it wouldn't be beyond belief if either
of them found themselves in a similar
position with Cersei yet Jaime and
Tyrion aren't the only characters who
could fulfill the valonqar prophecy
among other potential Cersei assassins
is Iyer who hasn't had a chance to cross
the Mad Queen off her kill list yet for
her part in Ned Stark's death okay
totally crazy theory time now what if I
uh got hold of the decapitated dwarf
head that looked like Tyrion and which
kyvan took to use for his work in season
five she could then take its face and
choke Cersei as a Tyrion look-alike in a
similar stunt to the one she pulled on
Walder Frey's men at the start of season
seven or what if I uh put Jamie to death
for trying to kill her brother bran back
in season one and then she used Jamie's
face to fulfill the prophecy poor aya
could make use of the newly deceased
Littlefinger's face to slip back into
Circe's court under the pretense of
providing her with intel on her northern
enemies another character that many of
us are probably itching to see get his
just desserts before the series is over
is Gregor Clegane
aka Sir Robert strong the undead
mountain it's been a long time coming
but after the hounds fighting words to
his brother in the dragon pit it
certainly looks like they're teasing
cleganebowl for season eight for anyone
who doesn't know Clegane Ball as a fan
theory that the story arcs for the two
brothers Sandor and Gregor Clegane will
culminate in an epic face-off
now on the surface Gregor would appear
to have the upper hand against Sandor
being larger stronger and most
importantly now undead but I feel the
show has spent time thrusting the Hound
into situations where he's confronted by
flames which he's scared of given his
childhood experience with fire I think
this may be foreshadowing a crucial
moment where he overcomes his fear which
he'll need to do to finally defeat the
mountain
I suspect that an ordinary weapon won't
be able to kill Sir Robert strong so
Sandor might do it with a dragonglass
blade or how about this for a wild
theory beric Dondarrion could light the
hounds blade on fire and the Hound could
then use the flaming sword to slice into
his undead brother's face in a moment of
sweet symbolic revenge
Sarek donned aryan status at the end of
season seven was uncertain as he was on
top of the wall as the ice dragon
blasted a huge chunk of the wall down
the last time we saw him and torment
though it looked like they were on the
part of the
all that was left standing but I'm not
sure if the lightning Lord will make it
through the whole of next season alive
as his death has been pretty heavily
foreshadowed in season seven now that
his good friend and chief resurrector
soros of Mira's dead barrack is on his
last life and barek himself pointed out
that the reason he's been brought back
from the dead is to help kill the white
walkers what I think could happen is
that Barrett goes into battle expecting
to kill the night came with a dragon
glass or flaming Valyrian steel blade
but it doesn't work on the icy sovereign
berrak will die heroically therefore but
not completely in vain as Jon Snow could
witness the death and realize that it
will take something more to kill the
night King I really hope this doesn't
happen but I'm fearful for our onion
night Davos Seaworth next season he's
one of the few good-natured characters
on the show having been loyal to the men
he served he was a friend to Shireen
Baratheon and he was instrumental in
saving Gendry from Melisandre and him
bringing him back into the story in
season seven but when he said recently
that all he'd ever done was lived to a
ripe old age I immediately thought uh-oh
are the writers planning to brutally
kill him off I really hope that's not
what lies ahead for Davos but it does
feel like his character arc could be
coming to its natural end there is one
loose thread though which means
resolution before we see Davos leave us
and that's his threat to Melisandre back
in Winterfell that he would execute her
if he ever saw her again
this brings us to the red woman herself
who departed Westeros this season in her
usual cryptic manner but gave a few
clues to her future when she spoke to
Varys on Dragonstone
during the conversation Melisandre said
she was leaving for volantis but that
she had to return to Westeros one last
time where she added mysteriously that
she would die the thing with Melisandre
though is that she's hard to kill she's
over 400 years old and she's survived
assassination attempts before like when
maester Cressen served her poisoned wine
in season two for a hint at how she
might go out though let's look back at
her encounter with ire in season 3 where
this happened I see a darkness in you
and in that darkness eyes staring back
at me we will meet again and let's not
forget that the red woman is still on I
is kill list aya now has a Valyrian
steel dagger which could be enough to
kill the red priestess in season eight
but I think she'll also have to remove
Melisandre's magical choker first as
well and remember that during
Melisandre's conversation with varus she
also revealed that he too had to die in
Westeros and that wasn't the first
encounter we've seen between Varys and a
red priestess back in Mereen and season
six Varys met with Kimbra who revealed
she knew about the time a sorcerer
castrated him and cast his manhood into
the fire Kimbra
also knew about the voice of Varys heard
from the flames which was presumably the
fate that lies ahead for him and which
it looks like Melisandre also knows
about and there was some possible
foreshadowing of the fact that Varys
will die even if it's not in this way
when Daenerys told him he must stand up
to her if he ever thought she was
failing as a ruler and that she would
burn him alive if she discovered he was
betraying her moving on to the Ironborn
I think that Theon could be a Greyjoy
casualty in season eight after
abandoning his sister Yara during
Euron's attack in season seven Theon
wants to redeem himself by launching a
raid to rescue her I can see the show
having Theon successfully free Yara but
there's a chance he might not survive
that final act of redemption alternately
Theon could survive and either he or
Yara could kill you're on during the
rescue and that would be an interesting
way to go as it'll put Yara back in
charge of the Iron Islands
now one character whose death could
shock a lot of fans and who I think has
a chance of dying is Sansa Stark
Sansa's death could be a heartbreaking
moment for fans of the lemon cake loving
Lady of Winterfell so what suggests that
the elder stark sister could kick the
bucket before the series ends well in a
letter that george RR martin penned back
in 1993 he revealed the five characters
he planned to survive the whole of his
book series those lucky five were
Daenerys Targaryen I a stark Jon Snow
bran Stark and Tyrion Lannister if this
original vision is something showrunners
Benioff and vice plan to stick to it
seems that Sansa will not make it to the
end and something that could foreshadow
Sansa's eventual demise is a
of her direwolf lady back in season one
the Starks have all had strong
connections to their dire Wars with only
John and I as died wolf still alive
although bran survived his direwolf's
death you could argue that summer died
around the time that bran lost his
personal identity and became the
three-eyed Raven Santa's been on quite a
journey on the show progressing from a
naive young girl with dreams of knights
and princes to becoming a more
politically savvy operator in the north
to get to this point though she's been
played betrayed and abused by various
people from Joffrey and Cersei to
Littlefinger a ramsay so you might
wonder how on earth could the TV show
kill her off after that well her death
might not be as a helpless victim rather
it could be heroic or noble in some way
for example defending the north or
Winterfell against a horde of invading
White Walkers then against answer
appeared to be displeased about her
brother Jon bending the knee to Daenerys
so how will she react when he arrives at
Winterfell with Dany and on top of that
what about when she discovers that he's
also a secret Targaryen will she still
treat John as one of the stark Wolfpack
I know that losing any of the characters
have been talking about would be a big
blow depending on who your favorites are
but there's still one really shocking
death the showrunners might decide to do
late in the season when talking about
the ending he's planned for his Song of
Ice and Fire series george RR martin has
said that it will be bittersweet and
that you can't just fulfill a quest and
then pretend life is perfect which means
that the hero or heroes we've favoured
are unlikely to get a perfectly happy
ending so although we will get some kind
of satisfying resolution it will also be
tinged with sadness which could mean
that one of the two main characters many
have rooted for over the seasons Jon
Snow or Daenerys Targaryen may have to
sacrifice themselves to defeat the night
king and his army the season 7 finale is
just paired up our heroes but the reveal
of John's Targaryen heritage could drive
a wedge between the couple if Danny
thinks he's a threat to her claim
alternately John and Danny could
continue to work together to defeat the
undead threat and either John or Dany
could be revealed to be azor Ahai or the
prince or princess that was promised in
the legend of azor Ahai the sword that
could defeat the darkness could only be
forged when the hero drove it into the
chest of his beloved Nissa Nissa and to
fulfill that prophecy Dany or John could
have
to forge a new light bring a sword by
plunging it into the heart of their new
love still george RR martin said in the
early 90s that John and Danny were two
of five characters who would make it to
the end of his books and he also told
the crew working on season 1 of the show
that bringing Danny and John together
was the endgame so if the show runners
do take the Ozora high route perhaps
bringing down your John back from the
dead could be one of Melisandre's final
acts before her own demise now I'd love
to hear who you think will get the chop
and who will survive to the end of the
game of Thrones and what are your
predictions for the final season make
sure you leave a comment and subscribe
for your chance to win one of these Game
of Thrones Funko pops I'll announce the
winner on an upcoming video so turn on
notifications to make sure you get my
new videos and if you enjoyed this your
support is really appreciated so don't
forget to leave a thumbs up and check
out some more epic Game of Thrones and
other videos by tapping the screen right
here
thanks for watching and see you next
time u BK movie lovers